maggio 2019
da qualche mese mi trovavo
medici senza frontiere in nord kivu
repubblica democratica del congo
lavoravo come medico in un pronto
soccorso di un grande ospedale rurale
peculiarità del contesto ci trovavamo a
400 chilometri di distanza in linea
d'aria da una regione colpita da
un'epidemia di ebola un virus è
responsabile di una grave forma di
febbre emorragica
nella nostra area non vi erano mai stati
casi ma nell'eventualità
seppur remota che il virus giunge fino a
noi ci stavamo preparando come
organizzavamo
simulazioni per imparare a vestirsi e
svestirsi
controllavamo i casi quotidianamente dei
territori circostanti
grazie al contact racing ha effettuato
dall organizzazione mondiale della
sanità e dal ministero della salute
congolese
avevamo creato un piano di gestione
dell'emergenza ad hoc per il nostro
contesto da attivare qualora arrivassero
i casi sospetti dove riporre le tende di
pre triage quali materiali reperire in
breve tempo dove isolare i pazienti
il tutto cercando di evitare il panico
tra la popolazione
parallelamente prioritario
organizzavamo delle attività per
sensibilizzare la popolazione e gli
operatori sanitari dei centri periferici
sul tema ebola cosa fosse come
riconoscerlo cosa fare nel caso di
pazienti sospetti
ora le strategie previste per un
contesto rurale congolese possono
sembrare lontanissime da noi ma ad oggi
in questo incipit non vi sono dei
termini che ritrovate
un giorno
arriva in pronto soccorso un bambino di
4 anni con sintomi molto sospetti perego
la febbre ed emorragie diffuse panico
penso o dio è arrivato ma tra tutti i
personaggi della mia infanzia me cari
dovevo scegliere lui
nello sguardo dei miei colleghi vedo la
mia stessa preoccupazione
sento ancora vivo il senso di grande
vulnerabilità provato in quel momento e
ricordo una consapevolezza cosa potevo
fare io come medico d'urgenza in quel
momento
relativamente poco per il paziente con
dei sintomi così avanzati sapevamo che
aveva basse probabilità di sopravvivenza
però potevamo fare tantissimo per
popolazione e per noi operatori sanitari
come applicando quanto imparato per
proteggerci isolare il paziente ed
escludere che realmente fosse ebola
altri concetti forse un po familiari ad
oggi
fine marzo 2020 una storia che purtroppo
conosciamo molto meglio scoppia il covip
io sto lavorando in un pronto soccorso
piemontese una delle aree
particolarmente colpite la nostra
quotidianità diventa vestizione
svestizione nei media si sente fin
troppo parlare di conta dei casi contact
racing inefficace di riorganizzazione
del modo di lavorare nell'emergenza si
rende palese una carenza di risorse non
solo economiche rispetto a un aumentata
domanda sanitaria da parte di una
popolazione spaventata
ed eccomi così a rivivere in prima
persona e nello sguardo dei miei
colleghi quel senso di vulnerabilità
provato allora benché io teoricamente
fossi più preparato
date le pregresse esperienze con i miei
colleghi ho condiviso il medesimo senso
di impreparata davanti a questa nuova
forma di lardi rade sconosciuta bene due
storie
due contesti differenti ma tante
analogie così a più riprese mi sono
posto delle domande
è possibile che in un sistema così ricco
di risorse e solido come reputiamo il
nostro mi sia trovato più vulnerabile
che in uno spartano ospedale rurale
congolese ci sono lezioni che possiamo
imparare dal parallelismo tra due
sistemi così agli antipodi
apparentemente secondo i nostri criteri
di giudizio abituali
possiamo fare tesoro di quanto successo
la risposta è sì e ruota secondo me
attorno a due parole fondamentali
consapevolezza della vulnerabilità e
preparazione
il co lead ha evidenziato brie e nella
nostra fragilità
come singoli ma anche come società
quella vulnerabilità da me provata
davanti al bambino col sospetto di ebola
nell'ultimo anno e mezzo abbiamo provato
in tanti perché tra ebola e covip non
c'è un'enorme differenza
possibile tra un virus che ha una
mortalita media del 50 per cento e
colpisce aree del mondo a risorse
limitate e covip vi sono delle
somiglianze
come sono entrambi responsabili di
epidemie che come tali mettono in
risalto le debolezze di un sistema e lo
pongono dinanzi a
ristrettezza di risorse rispetto a un
aumentata domanda
le strategie di risposta alle epidemie
si basano su dei pilastri fondamentali
che in buona parte sono indipendenti
dall agente infettivo responsabile dal
contesto in cui ci troviamo pilastri che
ritroviamo nelle linee guida di febbraio
2020 pubblicate dall organizzazione
mondiale della sanità e riprese dal
nostro ministero per la gestione del
covip
semplificando estrapolato alcuni
concetti
emergenza non è improvvisazione
si parte dall analisi del rischio
è fondamentale investire su sicurezza e
formazione dei propri operatori sanitari
è sempre fondamentale investire su cure
primarie prevenzione a posteriori non
c'è stata la giusta reattività sulle
indicazioni fornite si è investito
prioritariamente su terapie intensive e
affini sacrosante trascurando troppo il
ruolo cardine della comunità è carente è
stata un po l'attenzione verso la
sicurezza degli operatori questo ha
contribuito ad aumentare il numero di
casi i costi sanitari
meccanismi analoghi a pregresse epidemie
per cui quelle di ebola ora ad oltre un
anno dall'inizio del covip siamo più
consapevoli di debolezze ed errori
commessi come sfruttare questa presa di
coscienza
con la preparazione quella che in congo
mi ha permesso di gestire una situazione
stressante mai affrontata prima d'ora lì
eravamo più pronti perché medici senza
frontiere più abituata a lavorare in
determinati contesti e memore delle
pregresse esperienze ci aveva formato i
dati d'altronde lo dimostrano in una
un'epidemia di ebola in west africa nel
il tasso di infezione fra operatori
sanitari di medici senza frontiere ruota
intorno allo 0 4 per cento dieci volte
in meno rispetto al tasso di infezione
degli operatori sanitari nazionali
quest'ultimo tasso il 4 per cento è
paragonabile a quello da noi registrato
nell'ultimo epidemia e tasso di
infezione è proporzionale a morbidità e
mortalità
ora in italia dobbiamo guardare al
futuro e
a questo punto dobbiamo puntare sulla
preparazione magari anche imparando da
quegli interlocutori che erano abituati
a lavorare in situazioni e in contesti
che ci sembravano lontanissimi ma cosa
significa
prepararsi nella nostra realtà ora io
dico investire su formazione prevenzione
e prioritario sulla primary al scare un
settore da tempo sottovalutato primary
asker un termine che un po
impropriamente in maniera semplicistica
tradurremo come cure primarie
in realtà è
intende un nuovo modello di salute più
ampio multidisciplinare integrato che
fornisce risposte sanitarie che vanno
oltre il puro carattere biomedico ma
integra determinanti sociali economici
politici con cui la salute si manifesta
in ogni territorio
primary al che significa potenziare e
formare il territorio significa
investire su prevenzione su promozione
alla salute e su una medicina di tipo
proattivo cioè che vada a intervenire
prima che la malattia si aggravi
necessiti di ricovero
significa premere alt che
gestire il paziente
delocalizzandolo dall'ospedale significa
fornire un assistenza
al paziente proprio in quei contesti di
vita della persona quali scuole casa
comunità in un periodo di epidemia
significa anche ridurre il movimento di
persone all'interno della comunità e con
esso
contagi trasmissione
tutto ciò a fronte di una riduzione dei
costi
il coni ha finalmente dato la giusta
attenzione mediatica a questo argomento
l'organizzazione mondiale della sanità
ce lo dice da anni e chi lavora in
cooperazione lo sa la prima realtà è una
un settore scientifico da cui partire è
fondamentale
in periodo di epidemia così come nella
cronicità in congo come in italia
indipendente niente dalle risorse a
disposizione quindi ripartiamo da lì
come sostiene il dottor maciocco in una
lettera indirizzata lo scorso anno al
ministero al ministro della salute di
chi vi invito a leggere ci vorrà tempo
per fortuna c'è già chi è partito quindi
seguiamolo un esempio
il movimento phc prime righe now or
never una campagna italiana giovane che
dal 2018
ci fornisce un nuovo modello di cure
primarie virtuose ed efficace che si
ispira proprio ai principi della primary
al kers è un gruppo multidisciplinare di
professionisti della salute medici
infermieri antropologi cittadini che ci
sta indicando una via da percorrere per
migliorare le cure
seguì una maul e mi viene in mente
un'immagine
chi di voi è mai stato nella riserva
dello zingaro nel trapanese
è bellissima io ci andai
qualche mese dopo un grandissimo
incendio e quella nera devastazione le
aveva rattristato ci tornai dopo pochi
anni ed era un tripudio di
piante colori fiori una gioia ecco io
vedo il nostro sistema sanitario
nazionale come reduce da un incendio
e i movimenti come thc now or never vedo
colori e fiori quindi alimentiamo li
innaffiamo li questi fiori cerchiamo di
invertire quel fenomeno di sanità
ospedalocentrica percorso negli ultimi
decenni che fortunatamente anche grazie
al co lead è stato rimesso in
discussione
noi stessi specialisti ospedalieri
dobbiamo chiedere e supportare questa
transizione
solo così potremo dire di aver fatto
tesoro di questa drammatica esperienza
vissuta e aver aperto gli occhi sulla
realtà del nostro sistema sanitario
nazionale per cercare di renderlo
migliore grazie
[Applauso]